Pat McAfee good to see you pat hey great
to be seen you running the board back
there just a blue-collar guy I am
blue-collar things right here in Indiana
it's an honor to be here with you I tell
you I I know that these three read lot
by the way Dell 2fo I have the board in
front of me I'm just gonna show you
executive today rich I'm Brock would
start talking start talking 1 2 I slid
it I slid that red button now you
understand why I'm the audio executive I
have a lot of power in these hands
oh yeah yes no asking me to call you
something on the air of audio like the
Bill Walsh of audio yes and I think I
think we're learning today that without
you rich he's a pretty good gatekeeper
of audio himself yeah this is Giovanni
Giovanni karma you came on Pat came on
and you were in studio and he was saying
that he was the Bill Walsh of audio
executives because of his audio exec you
or do tree Oh on the business yes have
learned under him he has mentored and he
talked about him being the Bill Walsh of
audio a couple of days later we had the
actor keegan-michael key on the program
of course and we had Mike play three
different sound bites from the old
predator for the the actor who was in
the current movie predator okay and told
him that the Bill Walsh of audio was
gonna play these three sound bites the
Bill Walsh of audio didn't have the
sound up when he played oh yeah you
can't do that Bill Walsh of audio hey
you can't do that drop a couple passes
down again and you call a couple wrong
plays on the sideline a couple times
that's what I did that day I'm allowed
and said he bounced back he said he
bounces he's got the bounce back ability
how are you packed you've said you've
had a hell of a February we've been on a
move here no I know that by oh great
royal we right there your is it true you
signed with WWE this is signed with WWE
official content contributor to the
World Wrestling Entertainment of
franchise okay
and what do you would what's me none of
us know so I don't know in the WWE you
don't know but you're just gonna work it
out I'm just making videos and then I
send them it and then they just
whether or not they're gonna put him up
for instance the first one that they put
up with me sawing down a a live audience
from Monday Night Raw I was like loud
this audience was basically the worst
was this whole vibrated three-minute
video eloquently put about how the
audience was so like dull and and I was
we sent it to him in literally
conversation amongst me and my boys was
like we're gonna learn quickly like if
the WWE is gonna want to do is they put
the video up there like here we go there
crowd lost there they're like oh so now
you're burying your own fans it's like I
am NOT the WWE so it's just I'm making
content and they're figuring out whether
they want to put it up or not but
they've been so nice look if they hire
you they should know what they're
getting true and then three days later
did you get engaged I did man forevers a
long time mr. rich I it was so
impressive
thank you what you the links you went to
make this happen for those who don't
know how did what lengths did you go to
to Samantha's her name samantha is my
lady's name and she's she's the best
right she holds it all down I'm a very
busy person as are you I got a lot going
on I talk too much I get sick of me
she's able to handle it okay she's the
best she's been the best thing that's
really happened in my life and it got to
a point July I should have done it you
know July like her but it was her
birthday month so my mom was like do not
do not do it on her birthday because if
you mess this up her birthday is ruined
for the rest of her life right so my mom
zero confident my mom has been around me
for 31 years my mom knows if I mess this
up let's not ruin her birthday forever
but then there's months between July and
February so then football hat the
football season happen right a lot of
things happen football see your life I
don't know how you do stops but it
really is yeah so then Christmas comes
around
mm-hmm okay I'm like oh this is it this
is a little quick little break I'm a
Christmas I go and get Ireland two days
before I prepped for it
I go and get a ring okay I go getting
important step take a picture of the
ring after I bite they had to resize it
or whatever you know right I was gonna
go picking up the next day so then next
day I looked at the picture everyone's
like that's not a nice enough ring I
don't think that's a nice enough ring No
that she would say no but in my head I
knew that this was gonna get flexed
because I've been getting pressure from
my family her family going
my friends her friends so if I show up
with this rinky-dink thing which it
basically was it was not a great way I
knew that I was gonna get murdered by a
lot of people so I backed out I was like
all right that ring by the way is still
sitting at the store right now for sale
like not an offer I bought it
okay I'm selling it potentially back to
the store right or do you if you'd like
to get engaged anybody it's up for sale
Brockman I'm gonna say that it was not
good enough for your lady but it's good
enough for somebody else's it's not the
best way to sell no I'm sure cuz your
take oh hey hey hey I saw you flexing on
the internet with your access to certain
things it all makes sense now because
the people run the audio to all these
things that you're at probably came
under your tree that's why you're the
del to fo ladies of Instagram otherwise
we're not gonna have the mic del to faux
fire fest work he's where he's working
his way up ok so then now you finally
got your your ring so like a month and a
half before this happens I tell the boys
everybody at the office with my cake
after the Super Bowl will do will do
shows Monday Tuesday Wednesday after
Super Bowl and then I want everybody to
take like ten days off after that and
they're like alright sounds good
and that was when it all started cooking
my lady was like where we go I was like
I don't know you can figure that so she
started booking us entire trip she's
like have you ever been in a while I was
like no she's like let's go to Hawaii
perfect so in my head I'm like okay I'm
gonna get in this engage in white this
is it Moana this is gonna be a real
thing this is gonna be I'm gonna be a
hero Disney movies really happened yes
so then she she gets an email from the
people in Hawaii from the hotel in
Hawaii it's like here's a list of events
that you guys can do okay helicopter
what to the waterfalls was an
option so in my head I'm like were in
Hawaii there's an option to go to a
helicopter to a waterfall that feels
like so I'm like wow let's do the
helicopter waterful I've always loved
waterfalls are you shining it off like
she's setting it up though so she's like
okay she's emailing as a person from the
hotel bathroom so now we get to
helicopter options you never go with the
cheaper helicopter so that that ring in
the helicopter the cheaper ones both got
left side one with the expensive one
yeah very expensive huge huge change
helicopter experiences for me I've never
been in a helicopter that big it's like
a Tony Stark Ellicott the photo it was
an Escalade it was a big big boy a
Maybach I've only been on tiny little
helicopters like for instance I flew one
to stagecoach one year yeah from LA so I
didn't have to hit all the traffic and
it was a tiny little thing and I felt
like we're gonna fall from the sky every
two minutes I was scared that was gonna
ruin the engagement turns out we paid a
lot of money for that helicopter there's
good reason that thing was sturdy in the
sky right
so we hop on this helicopter we fly to
like this coffee bean thing and I don't
care about any of that then we hop back
in the air we fly around and this guy
flies us to a part of the Big Island
that is a rain forest like nobody lives
there it's an actual rain forest and he
flies us into like these 35 waterfalls
and it's like avatar we flew into avatar
and then he I'm like so in my head I
hadn't told the helicopter people what's
gonna happen right I hadn't told did you
did you set up dinner and wait it's a
wig do you hear this romance
it's Lavin - I'm about to take you down
a little romance Fabio you keep going
so I'm known to be a very romantic guy
by the way okay obviously clever it's
not the case I think that is something
that my lady has grumpy Don me in the
past for not being the most romantic
urine so I hadn't told the helicopter
people either so it wasn't till we were
in the sky flying above avatar in the
unobtanium that I didn't really realize
that oh no like this guy has no idea
what I'm planning to do here so there's
no way to talk to the pilot though
unless you talk into the thing so I had
to ask
to the pilot to find out if we were
gonna get near a waterfall because we're
just flying over all these waterfalls
like am I gonna have to do this in the
helicopter like you know he was a medic
pilot in Iraq and Afghanistan this guy
he was he was barrel rolling yes over
these it was unbelievable I'm saying
when I say this it was the most
unbelievable so I go over the ear thing
I'm like hello it busts out every to set
like words it's like or week oh stool
befall and he's like excuse me like are
we getting close to a damn waterfall or
not he's like no no we're just gonna fly
around him then he does a direct like
about-face with the helicopter and
starts flying directly at the biggest
waterfall basically and I've ever seen
in my entire life at a thousand footer
and he lands it about 15 feet in front
of the waterfall on this little piece of
land that's about the size of this
studio right here
lands it down there and he's like all
right we got a hike through these rocks
to get to the waterfall is this close
enough for you I'm like me and my lady
walks in front of me I have the ring in
my back pocket of my jorts the entire
time right raised in my back pocket on
my dresser I've been sitting on it in
the helicopter while a barrel rolling
while right the Shepherd coffee bead
thing like I just have this sitting into
my back pocket right so as we get out we
start hiking I like to lean over the
guys here I'm like I'm about to propose
right now so if you get a photo that'd
be great he was like what were you gonna
do it for you I wasn't yours yeah we're
gonna be here I was gonna fly the
helicopter myself and he was like what
if I was gonna take photos like if this
is too much conversation he said okay by
this point though this guy and I have a
pretty good relationship he's a military
guy idiots we're pretty much we have a
good relationship he's almost
messing with me at this point right
she's in front of me so we have to hike
down these rocks a little bit and I
didn't think about it Waterfall very
cold we were very cold the water
wonderful you're just getting rain it's
following no on you that's the fall part
yeah Pat mcafee there's sleeveless -
yeah sleeveless hoodie in jorts just
because it had to be on brand keep it
real you know I mean of course real G's
would silence like lasagna exactly so I
get out there and I set her up with like
oh we're gonna do a one photo and we're
next to each other and
we're at a waterfall things and then I'm
like okay this is gonna be a time I'm
doing you're standing on lava rocks
right those can be rugged they can be
jagged so I'm going to get the ring out
of my back pocket Oh No and I'm holding
the I've a death grip on this ring right
because if it goes down it's done
forever finished so she grabs my head
like while I'm trying to like get down
cuz she wanted a kissing photo in front
of the waterfall yeah so while I'm
trying to pull the thing out of my back
pocket she's like kissing me right and
I'm in the picture the guy my guy is
just taking a bunch of photos there's a
photo of me like holding the ring out
while she's kissing me then I get down
on a knee do the whole thing like I want
to spend forever with you but she hits
me thinks I'm joking right she thinks
I'm joking at this point yeah and then
she does the yes starts bawling the
whole thing happens the ring ends up
being too big anyway she it's like right
now she won't take it off to go get it
resized but that thing is just bouncing
around like a rubber band on her hand
it's unbelievable well done thank you
thank you sir a tional border caper
thank you so then we hike out of there
back up to where the Cadillac helicopter
was parked and there was just like a
little tiny strip of grass in front of
that he was like I'm gonna set up a
picnic for you guys is that okay I was
like of course of course it is so I
turned to Sam she didn't hear that
question all right so I perfect thank
you it's going to do that have a little
crazy goes in health nuts what a story
that is now there's so much news to get
to I want to get ya cousin is worried
before we do the host of the Pat McAfee
show 2.0 recently had on his show Joe
testator oh yeah how was the chemistry
great I honestly he actually has a fort
he bought a for the brand shirt and a
for the brand Christmas sweater because
his child kicks at Boston College
he's very Italian I'm from Pittsburgh
which is basically all it
it was a good it was a good
give-and-take I felt very good
so I mean ESPN executives might be
everything if they're looking for any if
you don't mind me saying if they're
looking for an Indianapolis cult Peyton
Manning might be their first stop I
would do the same okay
but where is Payton doesn't want to do
this
mm-hmm until Eli's out of the league he
doesn't want to be sitting on Monday
Night Football in the booth hey uh you
know there's a third 32:3 game going on
here
Eli threw two interceptions yesterday
Dewayne Haskins is sitting there waiting
for a role he's in the role of being
analyst you know I mean it's an awkward
spot he's wait until he law is done
mm-hmm then he might if there's an
opportunity do that none of my brothers
are quarterbacks in Nina okay so check
that box yep cuz that's what the combine
is about right now it's checking boxes
yep we're checking that book for
chemistry we've already checked that box
test and Mack good name boards test and
Pat what would you what would you prefer
all right so test and Mack we got the
chemistry yeah you don't have any
brothers that you're concerned about
being in an awkward after criticize no
I'll bury Adam Vinatieri fine after okay
very good but you get it yeah okay so
let's go write honestly we have some
game tape review you were in Lambeau
Field for Fox this year we've got game
tape good stuff that we could send their
resume real right we got a lot of things
we honestly got a lot of what do we have
I mean pitch it Pat yeah we have is a
man who knows a lot about the game first
first-class experience with the
Indianapolis Colts front row seat to
Peyton Manning operating and also Adam
Vinatieri drafted by a Hall of Famer
Bill Polian mm-hmm got to learn the
ropes weren't from an undefeated team to
almost a completely defeated team yes I
mean I've seen football and its best and
I've seen it very much at its worst I've
pointed 10 times and a half before I've
seen what terrible football looks like
you blew up trending holiday didn't you
you know how to hit I'm not scared of
tackle I'm not scared to be certainly if
the Kyler Murray says exactly smaller
turns out I got him on a ruler
goddamn on a ruler okay I'm not scared
to have a perfect passer rating on
Thanksgiving in the biggest turkey bowl
of all time I'm not scared to do okay
and also I think the biggest thing on my
resume is enriched this might sound like
a shot at you it shouldn't be okay
thanks the voices of the NFL for far too
long
have made the fourth down a pee break
down as you know come on you know not
you not you love me I'm not a love do
not lump not you that was a broad brush
I just painted with there but most
people that are enriched aizen's exact
positions who have turned the fourth
downs of the world into a peeing suit
I've turned it into must-see internet
video I've turned fourth downs into a
must-see situation the most boring down
in a lot of people's eyes for years and
years and years since the game was
created I have turned into some I would
say this but some have said the most
electric town in football okay
Matt Hasselbeck said most entertaining
playing football right whatever I'm
talking about it I imagine what I could
do and it for other three doubts hashtag
for the brand for cash punters are
people too now you just now you have
just mentioned a guy that you have to
compete I think Hasselbeck should get a
look at the game house the third guy so
I think I should be a third your third
man I think so I mostly because I
couldn't tell you a single thing about
cover to now this is it now let's get
now this is what we got it before we get
to the news got to talk about the
Achilles heels here okay so I can't talk
about the cover too by the way
love learning things okay very coach of
your sponge bill Paul I am a sponge Bill
Polian drafted me I didn't know how to
punt said we think you'll figure it out
he was right he's all a favor now the
last that's the my last question for you
on the Achilles heel yeah
you know Paul Ian's on staff there yeah
they asked him for an assessment he had
oh is that a problem
he told me to punt about forty yards at
the end whenever we were just getting
crushed when we were just almost
completely defeated he asked if I could
punt the ball 40 yards with a 500
hanging time which both of those things
are great and all that but he actually
built incentives into my contract to
average like 45 or so
thing like that for like an extra
million so I'm like yeah I could do that
for you but we should go back to the
negotiation table he ended up leaving
and then I came back so our last
conversation might not have been the
greatest but I think he would I think
he'd go to bat for me okay I think Bill
Polian would second second thoughts here
okay no not for me
okay all right boy he also oh I don't
know let's hope Bill Polian doesn't
carry a lot of weight up there the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience